de raffinerie mais également les
blocages des centrales nucléaires on
verra d'ailleurs si le gouvernement
dispose de davantage d'informations sur
un possible accord entre la CGT de Total
énergie et la direction de total car on
a entendu que lors des âgés des
assemblées générales des grévistes sur
les différentes raffineries qui étaient
bloqués certaines certains syndicats de
la CGT ont décidé de lever la grève donc
on voit que il y a comme cela
l'évolution une évolution en ce moment
sur les différents sites et enfin la
troisième question posée par un
président de groupe aujourd'hui et c'est
autour du drame du meurtre de la petite
Lola puisque le président du groupe LR
au Sénat Bruno Retailleau va interroger
le Gouvernement sur ce sujet et qu'on a
vu que et bien l'exécutif avait évoqué
effectivement ce drame à la sortie du
Conseil des ministres puisque Olivier
Véran a expliqué que le Conseil des
ministres a salué ce matin le courage
des parents de là qui font face à
l'indicible je cite les parents nous
demandent de nous montrer collectivement
en soutien de ce qu'il traverse sans en
rajouter a dit le porte-parole du
gouvernement à la sortie du Conseil des
ministres l'exécutif qui dénonce depuis
24 heures elle est récupérations
politiques de la droite mais aussi de la
droite de la droite et de l'extrême
droite mais qui reconnaît aussi un cette
exécutif le gouvernement et que
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
ces occf elle pourrait être mieux
appliquée en France donc on verra quel
sera le ton de cet échange entre Bruno
Retailleau et la chef du gouvernement au
cours de cette question et donc ils
avaient de banque qui se trouve au Sénat
cet après-midi et donc jusqu'à 16h30
environ le 49-3 ne pourra pas être
appliqué puisque la première ministre
est ici mais peut-être juste après cette
question ira-t-elle à l'Assemblée
nationale une ouverture il y a une
fenêtre qui s'ouvre comme cela pour
l'exécutif après 17h c'est en tout cas
ce que nous dit et bien le staff ce que
nous disent des collaborateurs des
membres du gouvernement en attendant
au Sénat
[Musique]
il est donc adopté sous les réserves
d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
notre œuvre du jour rappelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
notre séance est retransmis en direct
sur Public Sénat et sur notre site
internet chacun sera attentif au respect
des uns et des autres et à celui du
temps de parole je donne immédiatement
la parole au président Jean-Claude
Roquier pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre après la crise des
gilets jaunes et la pandémie de covid-19
qui a mis à l'arrêt le monde durant deux
années notre pays est confronté depuis
plusieurs mois un nouveau choc
économique majeur avec l'explosion des
coûts de l'énergie et puis largement de
très fortes de prix des matières
premières et de l'alimentation
cette accélération de l'inflation en
partie importée frappe désormais toute
notre économie et le quotidienne le
comporte engendrant de fortes tensions
sociales dans de nombreux secteurs les
revendications de revalorisation
salariale sont bien sûr légitimes dans
un contexte inflationniste auquel nous
étions plus habitués nous devons
entendre ce qui demande une répartition
plus juste de la valeur ajoutée à
laquelle il contribue et une
rémunération digne leur travail la
solidarité doit aussi continuer à
s'exercer envers les plus fragiles
dans ce climat social tendu le dialogue
la négociation doivent demeurer les
outils de la sortie de crise en
particulier dans les raffineries et où
les transports publics les rois
négations sont connues et ont pu
s'exprimer elles ne peuvent cependant
plus justifier un blocage indéfini notre
économie oui de pénaliser des millions
de personnes et d'entraîner le pays dans
une boucle de récession nous sommes dans
la première ministre la volonté de notre
gouvernement a eu vrai pour le pouvoir
d'achat et le niveau des Français nous
nous comptons aussi sur la
responsabilité des entreprises pour
répondre selon long terme aux attentes
des salariés madame la Première ministre
comment comptez-vous maintenant agir
pour répondre aux attentes de nos
combattants
pour vous répondre la parole du Kev
Adams la première ministre
monsieur
le sénateur monsieur le Président
Roquier
je sais que vous êtes
dans un département où la voiture n'est
pas un luxe c'est une nécessité pour le
travail pour le quotidien et je sais
votre attention votre attention
particulière à tous nos compatriotes qui
veulent vivre de leur travail qui
s'inquiètent face à la montée des prix
qui subissent deux plein fouet les
tensions d'approvisionnement dans les
stations services et craignent le
blocage du pays monsieur le Président
Wauquiez c'est préoccupations ce sont
aussi les nôtres certains cultivent les
inquiétudes et veulent les changer en
colère nous tout comme vous monsieur le
Président nous voulons y répondre
apaiser le pays et rassembler les
Français
aussi pour protéger nos compatriotes
face à l'inflation nous avons pris dès
le précédent quinquennat des mesures
fortes avec un bouclier tarifaire dès
octobre 2021 en juillet vous avez voté
des textes d'urgence en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat et plus récemment j'ai
annoncé la prolongation des boucliers
tarifaires et le maintien jusqu'à
mi-novembre de la remise de 30 centimes
sur les carburants ce sont les mesures
les plus protectrices d'Europe et nous
avons l'inflation la plus basse de la
zone euro
mais je car je garde une conviction une
conviction que nous avons en commun sur
bon nombre de ces rangs une conviction
partagée par nos compatriotes le pouvoir
d'achat durable viendra du travail alors
concernant particulièrement les salaires
vous le savez notre pays dispose d'un
système unique au monde de
revalorisation automatique du SMIC de ce
fait le SMIC a augmenté de 8% en un an
c'est-à-dire plus que l'inflation qui
est autour de 6%
cette augmentation doit conduire en
conséquence à une revalorisation des
grilles salariales dans les différentes
branches professionnelles la dynamique
est lancée puisque depuis le début de
l'année plus de 500 accords de branches
sur les salaires ont été signés
mais au-delà je l'ai dit je le crois et
je le répète les entreprises qui le
peuvent doivent augmenter les salaires
elle le doivent d'autant plus dans le
contexte d'inflation et elles ont une
responsabilité particulière si elles ont
réalisé plus de profits malgré le
contexte
pour y parvenir des négociations doivent
se tenir dans les branches et dans les
entreprises et elles doivent avoir lieu
rapidement car j'en suis convaincu la
seule solution vient toujours du
dialogue social le blocage le refus de
la discussion par une minorité ou la
grève préventive ne sont jamais des
solutions et je pense ici à tous les
Français qui rencontrent encore
aujourd'hui des difficultés pour trouver
du carburant heureusement la situation
s'améliore mais nous serons mobilisés
jusqu'à un retour à la normale je vous
remercie
monsieur le président
la France rurale la France périphérique
sans transport collectif suffisant ont
besoin de se déplacer de voiture et les
voitures sauf les électriques ont besoin
d'essence il faut appuyer les stations
de service dans cette France là la
voiture était indispensable et
contrairement au centre-ville qui la
bannissent son ouvrage son usage est
apprécié et le terme bagnole n'y est pas
un gros mot merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
j'ai donné la parole à notre collègue
Daniel Breuillet pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire
c'est le président madame la Première
ministre ma question est simple
travaillons-nous pour rien Conseil
national de la refondation travail
transpartisan dialogue de Bercy votre
gouvernement démultiplie les annonces et
les rendez-vous dit de concertation mais
en même temps vous laissez planer depuis
plusieurs mois la menace du recours
éventuel potentielle à l'article 49-3 de
la Constitution et cela sur les sujets
essentiels de la vie des Françaises et
des Français les retraites l'assurance
chômage le projet de loi de finance
cette conception de la démocratie est
déroutante surtout dans ce contexte de
crise multiple et d'inquiétudes
grandissante des citoyens comme des
collectivités les mobilisations contre
la vie chère l'inaction climatique ou
pour la hausse des salaires montre bien
les attentes de nombre de nos
compatriotes les députés ont en
responsabilité face aux besoins de
justice sociale et écologique largement
amender le projet de loi de finance
c'est le rôle des consensus ont été
trouvés par exemple pour que ma prime
rénove finance davantage des rénovations
globales que des petits travaux ou
encore pour taxer à 35% des super
dividendes je pense également au crédit
d'impôt pour le reste à charge de tous
les résidents néhpad madame la Première
ministre alors que vous choisissez des
courteter les débats au moyen du 49-3
prenez vous l'engagement de présenter au
Sénat le projet de loi de finance
enrichi par le travail parlementaire de
nos collègues députés pouvez-vous nous
assurer que nous ne travaillons pas pour
rien et nous confirmer que nos
amendements sénatoriaux n'ont pas
également vocation à disparaître dans
les poubelles de tri présidentielle ou
bien nous préciser le cas échéant qu'il
faut désormais soumettre nos amendements
directement au président de la
République
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
et mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
messieurs les sénateurs Daniel Bruyer
merci pour votre question merci d'abord
d'avoir souligné en préambule la
démarche qui est celle du gouvernement
depuis des mois désormais celle de la
concertation de la main tendue de la
volonté farouche de travailler en commun
et d'arriver à trouver au-delà des
clivages politiques traditionnels
des voix des chemins de crêtes pour
pouvoir travailler ensemble à l'intérêt
général pour notre pays il en est ainsi
avec l'examen du budget vous l'avez
souligné c'est le huitième jour du débat
à l'Assemblée nationale sur la partie 1
du projet de loi de finance les débats
sont riches ils sont passionnants
passionnés évidemment certains consensus
sont pu être trouvés et le gouvernement
par la voie de la première ministre a
déjà annoncé que quel qu'en soit l'issue
il s'engageait à reprendre un certain
nombre d'amendements qui avait permis
d'enrichir le texte venant des majorités
et des rangs des oppositions
même la sénatrice vous dites tous si je
vais faire le compte à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle nous en sommes à
8 milliards de sur dépenses il nous
devions tenir compte de la totalité des
amendements des oppositions tel
qu'adopter en première lecture 8
milliards qui ne sont pas financés 8
milliards qui correspondraient ou à de
la dette supplémentaire pour notre pays
ou à des impôts supplémentaires pour les
Français or
si le chemin du dialogue est réel et si
la volonté de trouver des compromis je
le redis et permanente nous ne renierons
pas sur un certain nombre de principes
qui sont chers au président de la
République à la première ministre et à
cette majorité il n'y aura pas de hausse
d'impôts il n'y aura pas de hausse de la
dette nous ne décritterons pas
l'ensemble des mécanismes qui ont permis
à notre pays de retrouver son
attractivité et sa richesse en 5 ans et
nous ne rénierons pas nous ne renierons
pas les engagements qui ont été pris par
le Président de la République lors de la
dernière campagne présidentielle et pour
lesquelles il a été élu je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre retenez nos
propositions comme les taxations des
super profits la démocratie sans
dialogue social et sans Parlement ce
n'est plus tout à fait la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant
au président Claude Malhuret pour le
groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoire monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre les idées
des CGTistes si j'ose a collé ces deux
mots sont simples
total ne nous accorde que 8%,
vengeons-nous sur les Français ouvriez
bloqué dans les queues des stations
services infirmières en panne et leur
patients qui attendront artisans ou
chantier suspendus le syndicalisme
tranche c'est ça des salariés payés le
double de la moyenne qui empêche les
autres de travailler et qui en plus
prétendent les défendre à tous ceux
tenter de croire à cette arnaque à tous
ceux tenter de croire à cette arnaque je
voudrais rappeler ce dicton on finit
toujours par payer le joueur de Pipo le
comble du cynisme c'est quand on apprend
que ces grèves n'ont rien à voir avec le
pouvoir d'achat mais que c'est réglement
de compte à CGT chorale les dures de la
Fée des chimie mécontent que Martinez
fidèle à sa conception de la démocratie
et nommée tout seul sa successeur qu'il
trouve trop molle déclenche la grève
pour le déstabiliser
pour les faire taire il en rajoute dans
la radicalité sur le dos des Français
comme toujours personne n'est dupe et
l'automne show que nous promettent les
agents d'ambiance de l'agit propre
piétine les grèves sont condamnées par
une majorité de Français la journée
d'hier fut un échec comme le fut
dimanche la marche des gros chômasistes
de la nuque emmenés par le Che Guevara
de nations
la prochaine étape la prochaine étape
est encore plus obscène la récession
guette la planète le prix de l'énergie
met des usines à l'arrêt les Français
vont avoir froid cet hiver mais la même
CGT pour la plus grande joie de Poutine
empêche la maintenance des centrales
nucléaires qui nous permettraient de
surmonter l'arrêt du gaz russe madame la
Première ministre vous avez commencé de
prendre les réquisitions qui s'imposent
pouvez-vous nous assurer que vous
poursuivrez toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour que 90% de 90% pardon
ne puisse interdire à la moitié de la
France de se déplacer et que quelques
centaines d'autres ne puissent empêcher
nos concitoyens de se chauffer au cœur
de l'hiver
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs des sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Malhuret
le conflit social chez Total et so a des
répercussions dans tout notre pays et
touche le quotidien de millions de
Français
comme vous monsieur le Président malgré
j'entends et je partage les
préoccupations de nos concitoyens qui
créent de ne pas avoir de carburant pour
aller travailler que leur aide à
domicile ne puisse pas passer qui
craignent de devoirs renoncer à
retrouver leurs proches pendant les
vacances de la Toussaint
pour eux nous devions agir fort et vite
en lien avec le président de la
République le Gouvernement est
totalement mobilisé et je réunis
quotidiennement une cellule
interministérielle de crise pour
coordonner l'action des services de
l'État
dès les premiers jours de la grève nous
avons pris des mesures pour augmenter
les livraisons de carburant dans les
stations services nous avons notamment
libéré des stocks stratégiques de l'État
nous avons augmenté les importations
nous avons autorisé l'ouverture des
dépôts et les livraisons le week-end ces
mesures ont eu des effets importants sur
les livraisons de carburant et ces
derniers jours elles étaient jusqu'à
deux fois plus importante qu'en temps
normal mais les inquiétudes des Français
contenus des inquiétudes des Français
fascaux face aux risques de pénurie nous
avons assisté à une augmentation de la
demande plus forte que cette
augmentation des livraisons aussi il
était essentiel de sortir du conflit
social je me suis impliqué
personnellement pour que le dial social
et lieu chez So et chez Total et dans
ces deux entreprises des accords ont pu
être signés avec des syndicats
représentant une majorité des salariés
quand il y a un accord majoritaire le
travail doit reprendre une minorité ne
peut pas ne doit pas bloquer le pays
c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
demandé au préfet de réquisitionner les
personnels nécessaires au fonctionnement
dans certains dépôts aujourd'hui avec la
fin du conflit social chez Esso et
l'ensemble des mesures prises par le
gouvernement la situation continue à
s'améliorer nettement au plan national
ce matin 20% des stations étaient en
rupture sur au moins un produit elles
étaient 30% ce week-end et peut-être
plus précisément parce que la situation
peut être contrastée par territoire je
voudrais souligner que la situation
s'améliore sur tout le territoire dans
les hauts de France on était à 55% de
stations en rupture il y a une semaine
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 15%. en
Île-de-France avec le débloqué pardon la
situation ce s'améliore également avec 8
8 points de moins sur le nombre de
stations bloquées et dans votre région
en Auvergne Rhône-Alpes le déblocage du
dépôt de Feyzin permet des améliorations
sensibles depuis hier matin nous sommes
passés de 36% à 26% de stations en
rupture je sais que la situation est
encore difficile pour beaucoup de nos
combattriotes mais la dynamique est là
et je veux une nouvelle fois appelée les
salariés grévistes à reprendre le
travail il est inacceptable qu'une
minorité bloque un pays et de notre côté
monsieur le Président nous continuerons
à agir jusqu'au retour à la normale je
vous remercie
la parole est maintenant au président
Bruno Retailleau pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre depuis dimanche dernier la
France est sous le choc
Lola une jeune fille de 12 ans
a été sauvagement agressé et les mortes
agressée par une ressortissante
algérienne qui n'aurait pas dû être sur
le sol français
depuis dimanche des voies s'élèvent pour
que d'autres devoirs se taisent pour
imposer le silence
pour bâillonner le débat mais l'essence
même de la démocratie mes chers
collègues précisément cette
questionnement c'est le débat le meurtre
de Lola me rappelle un autre meurtre qui
m'avait touché personnellement
le meurtrier à l'époque était depuis
plus de 10 ans situation irrégulière il
était sur le sol de France
il avait été frappé par trois occultés F
il n'était pas expulsé il a incendié la
cathédrale de Nantes il n'était pas en
prison
il avait une santé précaire mentale il
n'était pas un hôpital psychiatrique et
vous voudriez madame le Premier ministre
que nous nous taisions ce sont les
Français qui réclament des comptes et il
faut l'admettre le désordre migratoire
peut tuer si cet algérienne n'avait pas
été sur le sol français Lola aurait été
encore en vie j'ai une double question à
vous poser la première reconnaissez-vous
des défaillances de l'État
une part de responsabilité
la seconde que dites-vous aux Français
pour que ces tragédies et ces drames ne
se reproduisent plus
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la première minute
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
président
je crois qu'on politique quel que soit
les circonstances nous devons toujours
faire le choix de la dignité
[Applaudissements]
une jeune fille une jeune fille de 12
ans une jeune fille de 12 ans a été tuée
dans des conditions effroyables une
famille des amis des voisins un collège
sont en deuil et tout le pays partagent
leur émotion
c'est pour les parents de Lola que je
veux avoir mes premiers mots le
président de la République a eu
l'occasion de les recevoir hier et de
leur dire toutes l'émotion et la
solidarité de la nation et je souhaite à
nouveau dire à cette famille
au nom du gouvernement
et j'en suis sûr en votre nom à tous
notre plein soutien
et monsieur le Président Retailleau
savez-vous ce qu'on demandait les
parents de Lola du respect la paix pour
la mémoire de Lola et qu'on les laisse
faire leur deuil dans la dignité
nous le leur devons et je le dis
franchement je crois que la dignité nous
commande de ne pas exploiter la douleur
indicible d'une famille de ne pas
utiliser la mort d'une enfant à des fins
politiciennes
[Applaudissements]
ce que nous devons à la mémoire de Lola
et à toute sa famille c'est la justice
une enquête a été immédiatement lancée
les services de police ont pu identifier
et interpeller des suspects en quelques
heures deux personnes ont été mises en
examen par les juges d'instruction et
l'une d'elles se trouve en détention
provisoires
l'enquête se poursuit aujourd'hui pour
déterminer précisément les faits
et il y a une autre chose à laquelle je
crois profondément monsieur le Président
c'est à l'indépendance de l'autorité
judiciaire je ne vais donc pas d'autre
commentaires à faire laissons les
enquêteurs travailler
laissons la famille de Lola faire son
deuil en paix nous leur devons justice
ils l'auront et c'est la République qui
la rendra je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre vous vous
trompez en réduisant la mort de Lola un
simple fait divers je pense vous voyez
que la politique se diminue quand elle
refuse le débat je pense que la
politique ne peut pas se contenter de
pleurer sur les conséquences elle doit
en dénoncer aussi clairement les causes
elle doit affronter la réalité pour que
ces meurtres ne se reproduisent plus
madame la Première ministre que vous
êtes une responsable public chaque
responsable public doit avoir le courage
d'affronter la réalité et doit protéger
les Français avec une politique
insebandonne pas justement au laxiste et
au laisser faire migratoires vous devez
prendre des décisions tout de suite pour
aujourd'hui pour demain
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Loïc
Hervé pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances et la souveraineté industrielle
numérique ou plutôt à Monsieur le
Ministre délégué en charge de
l'Industrie
le Mondial de l'auto a été l'occasion
d'annonce politique d'importance pour
continuer d'accompagner la filière vers
sa transformation qu'il s'agisse d'un
entretien du président de la République
dans Les Echos ou des propres
déclarations du ministre Bruno Le Maire
toute la filière automobile française
des noms d'ordre au sous-traitants est
un Fleurot qu'il nous faut savoir
préserver malgré les contraintes
considérables auxquelles l'ensemble de
cette filière se trouve confronté qu'ils
agissent du coût de l'énergie de la
compétitivité ou des normes le virage de
l'électricité va nécessiter en soi des
évolutions majeures de l'outil de
production après les différentes vagues
du plan de relance de nouvelles aides
sont prévues
dans mon département de la Haute-Savoie
singulièrement dans la vallée de larves
l'industrie du décolletage est au cœur
de ses enjeux et avec quelques ETI mais
surtout une myriade de PME qu'il faut
accompagner une par une avec les
meilleures chances d'être aidé
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
garantir que les aides pourront bien
aller aux autres prises qui le méritent
comment envisagez-vous de garantir
l'accès équitable à ses aides pour
toutes les entreprises sans qu'elle
n'est l'obligation implicite d'avoir
recours à des cabinets chasseurs de
primes dont les rémunérations sont
indécentes et qui a moins de risques
d'autant le volume des aides versées je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégués chargés de la
distribution Lescure
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Loïc
Hervé cette question est vous l'avez dit
tombe bien puisque nous sommes la
semaine du Mondial de l'Automobile le
premier et le sol salon en Europe cette
année le premier depuis 4 ans auquel est
adjoint également le salon EquipAuto
donc on a toute la filière les
constructeurs et les équipementsiers
réunis à la Porte de Versailles sur vos
moments perdus je vous engage à y aller
parce que c'est toute l'industrie
automobile française qui brille vous
l'avez dit le gouvernement a accompagné
cette filière dans un moment difficile
la covid France relance pour l'industrie
automobile c'est environ 750 millions et
pour votre département que nous avons
visité avec Bruno Le Maire il y a
quelques semaines la filière de la
vallée de l'arbous y était là la filière
du décolletage ça a été le premier
département accompagné avec 54 millions
d'euros d'argent public qui ont conduit
à 125 au total millions d'euros
d'investissement pour accompagner la
filière on va continuer on va même
accélérer j'irai plus loin que ce que
vous disiez vous disiez l'objectif elle
est de préserver la filière non
l'objectif il est de développer de
s'assurer que l'industrie automobile qui
va prendre le virage de
l'électrification le face en toute
souveraineté en réindustrialisant nos
territoires et en développant ses
filières qui en ont bien besoin vous
l'avez dit pour cela il faut annoncer il
faut accompagner toute la filière y
compris les petits sous-traitants
qualificatifs que j'apprécie pas
beaucoup parce qu'ils sont petits par la
taille mais extrêmement important dans
la filière et notamment chez vous en
s'assurant que les 5 milliards d'euros
dont un milliard d'euros dédié à la
sous-traitance qui sont au sein de
France 2030 destinés à accompagner la
filière puisse aussi toucher les petites
et moyennes entreprises
je ne suis évidemment pas là pour
choisir la place des empreintes
entrepreneurs quel cabinet de conseils
ils vont choisir ou pas pour demander
tel ou telle aide mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que nous souhaitons que
les appels d'os soient simples que les
appels d'offres accessibles et qu'on
puisse même sur le terrain organiser un
accompagnement public des entreprises
pour qu'elles puissent remplir ses
appels d'offres on s'appuiera notamment
sur les chambres de commerce et sur les
pôles de compétitivité pour que les
entreprises pardon petite moyenne ou
grande puissent profiter à plein de
France 2030 merci
Monsieur Hervé merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre
pour vous répondre ça tombe mal le pôle
de compétitivité de la vallée de larve
il a été assassiné politiquement il y a
quelques mois donc il n'existe plus donc
pour ce qui est chambre de commerce il
reste des champs de commerce vous avez
raison mais la structuration collective
de dans la dans la vallée de l'arbre et
en Haute-Savoie ça reste quelque chose
de très important apprenons de ce qui
s'est passé ces dernières années avec
les trois vagues du plan de relance et
moralisons l'octroi des aides pour que
toutes les entreprises et la capacité
d'avoir des aides merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue Marie
Noël linemann pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste ils
avaient la parole monsieur le min
Istre de semaine de fleurons de notre
industrie aéronautique espacial passe au
pavillon américain
et deviennent propriétés de la même
société Aiko
la société excelia qui intervient dans
l'aéronautique le spatial l'armement
mais aussi dans le médical qui plus est
cette société devraient bénéficier du
programme France 2030 la société trad
spécialisée dans la technologie des
tests et analyses des effets de
radiation sur les matériaux et
composants électroniques fondamental
pour la recherche spatiale les avions de
haute altitude et l'armement entre
autres comment ne pas voir qu'il s'agit
là de secteurs de haute technologie
essentiel pour l'autonomie stratégique
de la France et qui concourt à notre
souveraineté industrielle comment
pouvez-vous laisser faire ça
doit-on revoir le sinistre scénario
consécutif aux décisions d'Emmanuel
Macron avec la vente des turbines
arabels essentielle pour les centrales
nucléaires à l'Américain général
électrique pour devoir aujourd'hui les
racheter au double du prix de vente sans
récupérer les licences pertin d'emploi
d'argent de savoir-faire vous auriez dû
vous en souvenir alors Monsieur le
Ministre pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
déclenché le décret Montebourg qui
permet au gouvernement de contrôler les
investissements étrangers en France dans
les secteurs clés que comptez-vous faire
pour qu'elle Célia et trad reste
française
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste déléguée chargé de
l'Industrie monsieur Lescure monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice linman
d'abord peut-être rappeler
le ce que vous appelez le décret
mondebourg qui est en fait la procédure
investissement est trajet en France qui
a été à la fois élargiée renforcé dans
le monde après sédent en accord
d'ailleurs entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
j'étais à l'époque président de la
Commission de la faire économique et
rapporteur général de la wapaq et
beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet nous
avons élargi les secteurs concernés nous
avons aussi renforcé la procédure de
contrôle du Parlement sur ces
investissements étrangers en France une
fois par an vous avez un rapport qui
vous êtes envoyé qui vous permet d'avoir
la liste des pardon la vis le nombre
d'investissements concernés et ceux qui
ont fait l'objet d'autorisation sous
conditions je vous rappelle qu'en 2021
dossiers ont été soumis à la procédure
dite Montebourg investissement étrangers
en France et sur ces 328 sans un cap 124
pardon est autorisé dont 67 sous
conditions allez plus loin suppose de
mettre en cause le secret des affaires
et parfois le secret de la défense
nationale et c'est pour pallier ce
défaut que dans le cadre encore de la
loi pacte nous avons voté une
disposition particulière qui fait que
sur des cas particuliers les présidents
des commissions des affaires économiques
du Sénat et de l'Assemblée les
rapporteurs généraux du budget peuvent
sur le coup du sucré ceux du secret
pardon examiner des cas particuliers
mais vous comprendrez bien que pour les
deux raisons en sus mentionnées je ne
peux commenter en détail des cas
particuliers comme ceux que vous
mentionnez sachez pour autant que ce
soit pour la société trad et pour la
société excellia vous mentionnez
évidemment nous avons à cœur les
intérêts stratégiques de la nation la
souveraineté industrielle industrielle
et les enjeux de ces crédit en France
quand nous ex dans ces dossiers et nous
l'avons fait et nous continuons à le
faire merci un homme
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Michel Dagbert pour le grand du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier
Duchamp ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion monsieur le
ministre si depuis 2004 les départements
assurent avec le concours de l'État le
versement de l'allocation au profit des
bénéficiaires du RSA l'exercice de cette
compétence a été et demeure au cœur de
bien des discussions entre département
et gouvernement successifs les
départements sont aussi en charge de
l'accompagnement social et ou
professionnelle de chaque bénéficiaire
cette politique publique participe et
c'est heureux à la cohésion sociale du
pays sans remettre en cause la
détermination des élus départementaux le
professionnalisme de leurs équipes et
tout en leur reconnaissant un certain
nombre de réussites il est à noter que
malgré la baisse significative du
chômage une longue liste de propositions
d'emploi reste non pourvu
les secteurs concernés sont diverses
serveur de café restaurant agent
d'entretien ATSEM aide à domicile à
déménagère voire même professionnel de
l'animation socioculturelle de quoi
réinterroger légitimement la déquation
entre les parcours d'insertion proposés
et la réalité du marché de l'emploi je
sais Monsieur le Ministre que quelques
départements se sont portés volontaires
pour une expérimentation celle-ci fait
craindre à une importante association du
secteur social une réforme qui selon
elle s'apparente à un retour du servage
n'ayant aucun doute sur la volonté qui
vous anime en la matière pouvez-vous
monsieur le ministre devant mes
collègues de la Chambre haute préciser
les contours de cette évolution des
politiques d'insertion et nous en donner
le calendrier
[Applaudissements]
ça nous oblige et ça nous oblige à agir
nous pouvons continuer à croire ou à
penser que la société serait quitte de
son devoir de solidarité une fois
qu'elle aura attribué une indemnité d'un
peu moins de 600 euros à une personne
dépourvue de revenus la conviction du
gouvernement la conviction que défend
devant vous et que la société sera
quitte de son devoir solidarité lorsque
leur a permis le retour à l'emploi parce
que l'emploi le travail et l'élément
d'émancipation d'autonomie de dignité et
la capacité à retrouver un revenu
comment allons-nous le faire nous allons
le faire avec un accompagnement plus
intensif des bénéficiaires du RSA et je
dis tout net devant vous il n'a jamais
été question ni de travail gratuit ni de
bénévolat obligatoire il s'agit de
formation au sagit d'accompagnement il
s'agit de remobilisation collective et
individuelle mais il ne s'agit ni de
bénévolat obligatoire ni de travail
gratuit c'est important à souligner
parce que ça ne correspond pas au modèle
qui est le nôtre le président de la
République l'a dit le RSA est un droit
inconditionnel pour tous ceux qui sont
privés de revenus le devoir de la
puissance publique de toute la puissance
publique et de garantir offre
d'insertion et de formation adaptée
personnalisée partout sur le territoire
et de ce que ces deux constitutions sont
remplies il y a une logique de droit et
devoirs pour faire en sorte que ceux qui
en bénéficient s'inscrivent dans ces
parcours de retour vers l'emploi et
d'insertion par l'emploi que
[Applaudissements]
de la parole maintenant à notre collègue
Monique Lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre le prix du gasoil
dépasse les deux euros le litre les
tarifs des différentes sources d'énergie
augmente considérablement les produits
de première nécessité tels que les pâtes
ou le beurre revoient leur prix
augmenter de 22 à
47%, la liste est longue de tout ce qui
concourt à la vie quotidienne des
Français dont une partie d'entre eux
n'aura pas d'autres choix que de se
priver dans les semaines à venir et nous
savons tous ici qui seront les premiers
à sacrifier des biens pourtant
indispensables à ce que l'on qualifie de
vie descente vous répondez prints
aléatoire défiscalisation et
désocialisation d'heures supplémentaires
rachat de RTT et autres mesures qui
finalement n'impliquent que les salariés
eux-mêmes mais vous refusez obstinément
de satisfaire notre demande et surtout
celle des salariés d'initier un grand
débat sur les salaires
les salariés ne demandent pas l'aumône
ils veulent vivre de leur travail vous
ne cessez de rappeler la valeur travail
souvent d'ailleurs pour stigmatiser ceux
qui en sont privés nous vous répondons
pas de valeur travail sans travail de
valeur et la valeur d'un travail se
mesure entre autres à l'aune de sa
rémunération depuis 2008 les salaires
des 10% les mieux payés ont augmenté
trois fois plus vite que ceux des 10%
les moins rémunérés est-ce que le
travail du patron d'une grande enseigne
vaut 300 fois le travail de sa caissière
il est temps de parler du partage de la
masse salariale dans les entreprises
quand metrez-vous à l'oeuvre conférence
nationale afin de poser enfin tous ces
sujets et soutenir par la même tous les
salariés de France
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail
je suis Olivier du choc merci monsieur
le Président Madame la signature vous
avez débuté votre question par
l'inflation et la situation de
l'inflation et je pense que vous auriez
pu faire le constater avec nous que nous
sommes le pays en Europe qui parlait
mesures mises en place le bouclier
tarifaire sur les questions énergétiques
les aides que nous apportons au ménage a
permis de réduire l'inflation le plus
possible nous sommes autour de 6,5%,
c'est beaucoup c'est plus que ce que
nous avons connu depuis 1985 mais c'est
bien souvent presque la moitié de ce que
connaissent nos voisins européens et
c'est aussi la démonstration que la
politique que nous menons protège les
Français vous nous appelez finalement à
une augmentation de salaire nous avons
une conviction c'est qu'une augmentation
générale de salaire ne se décide pas par
la loi la relève du dialogue social j'y
reviendrai nous avons une autre
conviction c'est que l'augmentation ou
l'indexation du SMIC que vous avez
parfois appelé de vos vœux dans les
débats ne concerne finalement qu'une
partie des salariés alors que notre
position est de nourrir de pousser au
dialogue social la première ministre l'a
dit nous engageons nous encourageons les
branches et les entreprises au dialogue
et dans le cadre du dernier projet de
loi de financement rectificatif vous
avez voté le Parlement a voté des
mécanismes permettant d'accélérer
l'ouverture des négociations dès lors
que un des niveaux de rémunération
conventionnelle serait inférieur au SMIC
il faut ajouter à cela des outils que
vous n'avez pas mentionné vous avez
parlé défiscalisation vous avez parlé
des socialisation vous avez oublié de
dire les efforts que nous faisons pour
améliorer le partage de la valeur faire
en sorte que les accords d'intéressement
soient plus facile faire en sorte que
les primes que vous qualifiez d'aller à
toi et qui bénéficie à des millions de
Français soit elles aussi plus facile à
verser je peux vous assurer que celles
et ceux qui peuvent en bénéficier sont
heureux d'en bénéficier bien plus que
les mots vous prononcez pour les décrire
ou pour les qualifier vous avez dit que
depuis 2008 et d'ailleurs cela interroge
sur la responsabilité des uns et des
autres tout ce confondus de sur cette
même période il y aurait un écart
croissant qui s'est creusé grâce aux
outils de redistribution dans notre pays
dispose l'écart entre le premier et le
dernier décide ne s'est pas creuser il
ne s'est pas creuser parce que nous
avons un système redistributif qui
récompenser les écarts entre les revenus
primaires et nous devons aussi en faire
une fierté dans quelques semaines
j'aurai l'occasion sous l'autorité de la
première ministre d'ouvrir une
négociation interprofessionnelle sur le
partage de la valeur ça sera une
première et j'espère que l'énergie que
vous mettez à critiquer la politique du
gouvernement vous pourrez l'utiliser un
meilleur espion en accompagnant cette
discussion
[Applaudissements]
mon énergie monsieur le ministre je
continuerai à la déployer au service des
salariés qui malgré tout ce que vous
venez de nous dire et dont une partie
effectivement relève du factuel
notamment sur les aides mais tout ce que
vous venez de nous dire
visiblement n'est pas entendu par la
majorité des salariés qui ont besoin de
cette conférence salariale pour que tous
les employeurs de France à la mesure de
leur moyen de la taille de leurs
entreprises soutiennent leur pouvoir
d'achat mais je constate que vous êtes
le plus pro à dégainer le 49-3 pour
mettre fin à un débat budgétaire
pourtant absolument riche comme l'a dit
tout à l'heure monsieur le ministre
varan qu'a organisé ce que les salariés
demandent de leurs vœux depuis un petit
moment maintenant
la parole est à notre collègue alchain
Larcher pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adressait à
madame la Première ministre à vous
entendre madame tout va bien alors que
les Français le constatent chaque jour
la France devient le pays de la pénurie
pénurie de médicaments pénurie de
carburant pénurie des transports
confrontés à la grève
pénurie d'électricité annoncée pour cet
hiver et face à ces pénuries ont fait le
terrible constat que le gouvernement n'a
rien anticipé
il aura fallu plusieurs semaines avant
de réquisitionner une partie du
personnel de quelques raffineries
résultat les Français font la queue
pendant des heures devant les rares
stations services ouvertes la grève
s'étend au centrale nucléaire on
centrale sur 18 était touchées hier
cette grève si elle se poursuit pourrait
provoquer une terrible pénurie
d'électricité
RTE prévoit d'ailleurs je cite des
conséquences lourdes cet hiver si la
grève se poursuit
qu'attendez-vous pour protéger les
Français des pénuries dans ces secteurs
stratégiques vous faudra-t-il comme pour
les raffineries attendre plusieurs
semaines pour agir allez-vous enfin
réquisitionnez toutes les raffineries
allez vous réquisitionner le personnel
des centrales nucléaires allez-vous
mettre en place un service minimum dans
les transports comme le prévoit la
proposition de loi de Bruno retaillod
votez au Sénat la situation exige du
courage et dit mesure forte mais en
avez-vous
pour répondre la parole est communiste
du travail
plein d'emploi de l'insertion merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice pour avoir la chance de
partager avec madame la Première
ministre un certain nombre de rencontres
avec les différents présidents de groupe
dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites je peux vous assurer que les
partenaires sociaux qui ont un
participer
pour je peux vous dire madame la
sénatrice que les partenaires sociaux
qui ont à participer au négociations
salariale dans les différents secteurs
ne se pose pas la question de savoir si
madame la Première ministre a de la
force et du courage il le constate ils
le vide et je peux témoigner des efforts
qu'elle met elle-même à propulser et à
promouvoir ce dialogue je voudrais
revenir sur deux aspects de votre
question deux aspects de votre question
le premier concernant les centrales
nucléaires comme dans l'ensemble des
secteurs nous encourageons à la
négociation et aujourd'hui l'entreprise
doit ouvrir un cycle de négociation et
nous espérons que ce cycle de
négociation soit aussi nature à
dissuader cette grève à l'empêcher et à
permettre un bon fonctionnement vous
nous protéger c'est le deuxième point de
votre question sur la question des
réquisitions je suis désolé de vous
rappeler madame la sénatrice que dans le
cadre du respect des droits
constitutionnels nous sommes évidemment
respectueux du droit de grève que la
jurisprudence en matière de réquisition
éclair que les réquisitions doivent être
proportionnées justifiées par un
impératif d'urgence ou de troubles à
l'ordre public et respectueuse de
l'exercice du droit syndical c'est ce
que nous avons fait en veillant à ce que
les réquisitions auxquelles nous avons
procédé pour ce qui concerne les
raffineries c'est un triste parfaitement
dans ce cadre c'est ce qui a d'ailleurs
permis au tribunal administratif de
Lille et de Rouen de considérer que les
décisions prises par le gouvernement
étaient conformes à la loi et qu'elle
pouvait ainsi s'appliquer nous pouvons
nous affranchir des règles du droit et
parfois même des principes
constitutionnels sauf que cela n'existe
pas et que ça serait la meilleure façon
d'être dans l'inefficacité avec des
décisions qui seraient immédiatement
censurées par la tribunal justice
administrative
[Applaudissements]
il faut agir et agir vite
d'euros perdu pour l'économie française
qui viennent creuser encore plus la
dette abyssale la vérité c'est que votre
gouvernement est débordé débordé par ses
contradictions débordé par son arrogance
débordé par son déni de la réalité par
son incapacité à ressentir une
quelconque empathie vis-à-vis des
Français qui galèrent toujours et
toujours plus dans notre pays où règne
excusez-moi la chiangli
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Rachid themal pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi ici d'être pour quelques
instants le porte-parole des régions des
départements des intercos des villes et
des villages notre pays c'est
collectivités qui encore une fois sont
très largement impactés par l'inflation
et qui voit leur coût multiplier par 8
à cette date rappelons quand même que
ces collectivités représentent 70% de
l'incent public entre pays et donc sans
leur rallongement ça dépend entier notre
économie qui s'effondrerait et des
emplois qui seraient détruits rappelons
qu'ici sont des sur ces bancs là nous
sommes tous à travailler au quotidien
avec les élus avec les associations
d'élus nous l'étions derrière nous-mêmes
nous étions d'ailleurs dans le
Val-d'Oise ce weekend avec mes collègues
ici présents et qu'est-ce qu'on constate
chez les élus locaux que nous
rencontrons d'abord pour la première
fois ils n'arrivent pas à boucler leur
budget c'est une première
ils nous disent qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
dans l'obligation de s'interroger sur la
fermeture de service sur la suppression
de poste et on ne peut qu'imaginer les
Français qui est dans quelques semaines
quelques mois iront dans leur piscine
dans leur gymnase les Coubron
porte-close parce que il n'y aura pas
pour les collectiers les moyens d'ouvrir
de les financer alors Monsieur mix la
question est relativement simple
qu'entendez-vous modifier dans votre
projet de loi de finances 2023 sur les
collectivités pour qu'enfin ces
collectée puisse fonctionner dignement
et répondre au service public je vous
remercie
de la transmission écologique de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur
le président madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateurs
quand des gouvernements vous soutient
ont baissé de 11 milliards la DGF il y a
de cela quelques années pour la première
fois depuis 13 ans un gouvernement celui
qui est dirigé par Elizabeth borne
propose de revaloriser le montant de la
DGF de 200 puis 320 millions et ces
chiffres vous seront présentés dans
quelques jours quatrième
ment un filet de sécurité
autre à construire pendant le PLF sera
inclus dans le PLF qui vous sera
transmis et ça n'est que la deuxième
étape de notre grande bataille qui
consiste d'abord à obtenir une baisse
des prix de l'énergie c'est ce qui se
joue demain et après demain au Conseil
européen et la réflexion plus que la
réflexion l'établissement d'un
dispositif de protection tarifaire pour
les collectivités pour les entreprises
qui ne sont pas couvertes par le TRV à
ce stade 1 on se bat à l'échelle
européenne 2 on utilise la contribution
sur les rentes pour solvabiliser des
dispositifs de compensation 3 on prévoit
un filet de sécurité plus plus pour
compenser ce qui reste
[Applaudissements]
très bien monsieur le ministre je ne
suis pas certain que le maire bessut
tiendrait les mêmes propos que vous
et je vous rassure j'ai bien indiqué
dans ma question que je parlais au
niveau de pour tous les bancs je ne
parlais pas que de mes amis politiques
je parlais de tous les bons je crois que
tous les sénateurs c'est attristie
rencontre les mêmes difficultés quand il
rencontre les rencontres les mères vous
nous parlez des villages tant mieux mais
quand on rencontre les maires des
villages ils nous disent la même chose
et je vous rappelle que vos dispositifs
fait que 45 millions de Français ne sont
pas inclus dans vos mesures et donc ils
vont être eux pénalisés aussi donc la
question on peut toujours tourner en
rond mais aujourd'hui ce qu'on propose
simplement les associations d'élus c'est
qu'il y a un bouclier fiscal pour toutes
les communes
pour toutes les communes et qui n'a pas
non plus leur capacité à investir dans
l'avenir ça vous pouvez au moins
l'accepter ou pas c'est ça la vraie
question qui nous est posée et puis il y
a aussi la question des bases locatives
etc parce que vous nous parlez vous nous
parlez de mesures mais je vous rappelle
je vous rappelle que vous retirez la
cerveuse c'est 8 milliards de moins pour
aussi pour les collectivités
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe les républicains
sur le président madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues monsieur le
ministre la réponse que vous avez
apporté à mon collègue temal ne nous
satisfait pas je voudrais vous rappeler
que comme vous le savez au 31 octobre
les contrats d'électricité de gaz se
termineront pour de nombreuses
collectivités territoriales et les
nouveaux contrats devront être signés au
1er novembre c'est-à-dire dans quelques
jours sous peine de coupure totale
ces régions ces départements ces villes
devront donc acheter l'électricité et le
gaz au prix du marché dans un contexte
dans un contexte de flambé débris de
l'énergie de nombreux élus locaux vous
ont d'ailleurs
alertés sur ce point chez nous en
Seine-Saint-Denis on nous annonce des
prix tout à fait insupportables une
multiplication par 15 des prix du gaz 32
du prix d'électricité en
Seine-Saint-Denis comme partout en
France une commune moyenne passerait
donc de 2 à 15 millions d'euros en
termes de dépenses d'énergie
comme vous en avez pris l'habitude
lorsqu'il s'agit des collectivités
territoriales et des élus locaux votre
réponse n'est pas à la hauteur monsieur
le ministre le ministre des comptes
publics a proposé une aide 438 millions
d'euros largement insuffisante s'il
avait s'il avait ouvertement souhaité
afficher son mépris pour les mères il ne
s'y serait pas pris autrement
surtout cette aide de s'appliquera qu'au
commune dont l'épargne brute c'est
fortement dégradé ces dernières années
comme d'habitude vous avez choisi de
sanctionner d'abord les bons élèves les
communes qui gèrent correctement
l'argent de leurs administrés monsieur
le ministre vous demandez beaucoup
d'efforts aux collectivités aux
entreprises aux Français vous avez
demandé aux salariés de porter des cols
rouler dans les bureaux vous avez
demandé aux écoliers de grelotter dans
les salles de classe les Français ont
consenti beaucoup d'efforts ils ont
constitueront ils ont consentiront
encore mais ils ne doivent pas être les
seuls à consentir ses efforts monsieur
le ministre que répondez-vous au nombre
maires qui ne savent pas aujourd'hui
comment ils feront face à la flambée des
prix de l'énergie doivent-ils sacrifier
les services à la population pour payer
leurs factures de gaz et d'électricité
pour vous répondre la parole au ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous avez utilisé un mot que
je n'aurais pas choisi
c'est le mot de mépris il y a plusieurs
manières de mépriser les gens et une de
celle-là c'est d'être dans le trans dans
la caricature et de faire en sorte de
présenter les choses d'une manière qui
soit totalement dévié
on peut avoir un débat il peut être
respectueux et il peut surtout reposer
sur des réalités la réalité c'est que
pour la première fois depuis 13 ans il y
a une augmentation de la DGF la DGF elle
a pas été désindexée par l'actuel
gouvernement elle a été par la majorité
de la du Sénat qui se trouvait de ce
côté-ci et elle a été baissée ensuite
par celle-là donc à un moment revenir à
la réalité c'est une nécessité sur les
tarifs sur les tarifs la preuve a
présenté ce que sont les tarifs cibles
une diminutification par 15 ou par 30
c'est en dehors de ce qui se pratique
partout et là le conseil c'est de ne pas
signer sur des niveaux qui sont
délirants d'opérateurs qui profitent de
la situation dans laquelle nous trouvons
faites aussi votre part en termes je ne
peux pas croire que vous passiez votre
temps dans vos départements à relayer
des fausses informations ou alimenter
une inquiétude au lieu d'insister sur
les dispositifs exister le rendez-vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est simple
[Musique]
les choses sont assez simples
la parole est à notre collègue Patrick
Chauvet pour le gros pignon centriste
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des Transports la
voiture électrique et sans conteste la
star du Mondial de l'auto et pour cause
puisque la vente des véhicules
thermiques sera interdite à partir de
2035 si cet objectif se justifie sur le
plan environnemental il fait peser un
risque majeur sur l'industrie automobile
française en l'état actuel des choses
généraliser la voiture électrique s'est
déroulé le tapis rouge à la Chine les
grands constructeurs européens ont
consenti des investissements colossaux
pour améliorer les performances
écologiques des moteurs thermiques avec
le tout électrique ces efforts sont
passés par pertes et profits nous sommes
en train d'offrir une industrie
d'excellence à l'Asie aujourd'hui la
moitié de la chaîne de valeur du
véhicule électrique est encore situé en
Asie la Chine contrôle 56% de la
production mondial de batterie des
batteries dont nous devons importer les
principaux composants quand nous les
fabriquons ici résultat nous ne sommes
pas compétitifs les voitures électriques
chinoises coûtent 20 à 30% moins cher
que les européennes les constructeurs
estiment qu'il leur faudra entre 5 et 7
ans pour résorber cet écart 19% des
voitures électriques vendues en Europe
sont d'ores et déjà fabriqués en Chine
et ce ne sont pas les dispositifs d'aide
à l'acquisition d'une voiture électrique
qui vont les aider la location avec
option d'achat ne sera pas possible
avant 2024 c'est bien pour cela que vous
venez d'augmenter la prime à l'achat qui
va passer de 6 à 7000 euros pour les
ménages les plus modestes ce faisant
nous allons massivement subventionné les
constructeurs chinois les États-Unis
viennent de réserver leurs incitations
fiscales au seul véhicules électriques
dotés de batterie produite en Amérique
ne peut-on pas aussi cibler nos aides
sur les constructeurs européens je vous
remercie
on veut répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge des
transports monsieur bonne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Chauvet vous avez raison
d'abord de souligner l'importance de ce
Mondial de l'Auto le premier depuis 4
ans et de souligner ce qui est sans
doute n'aurait pas été imaginable il y a
encore quelques années comme la rappelle
le ministre Lescure qu'il est
entièrement consacré consacré pardon aux
véhicules décarbonée en particulier aux
véhicules électriques vous avez raison
aussi d’alerter sur les risques sur les
risques d'atteinte à notre souveraineté
et de protection nécessaire notre
filière automobile face à ce service
vous avez deux réponses possibles soit
nous considérons que le choix de la
décarbonation de la transition
écologique pourrait être remise en cause
soit nous considérons dans cette
hypothèse que nous ne pourrions nous
pourrions faire l'économie de
l'investissement dans le véhicule
électrique massivement et rapidement
je crois que renoncer à des carbonation
renoncer la transition écologique
renoncée à l'électrification personne ne
le propose nous devons alors assumer
cette transition nous devons l'affronter
et sans être naïf ni excessivement
optimiste nous avons le démontré ces
dernières années que affronter cette
transition et ne pas la refuser pour se
réfugier si je puis dire dans le confort
du thermique ou du statu quo qui
d'ailleurs a montré que la baisse de
production était déjà là avant la
question de l'électrification nous avons
engagé une réindustrialisation et il y a
5 ans nous n'aurions pas pensé que la
France aurait pu vous avez souligner ce
point produire commencer à produire des
batteries et retrouver progressivement
et rapidement son indépendance car le
président de la République a fixé ce cap
il est aujourd'hui crédible nous pouvons
sur les batteries atteindre
l'indépendance de production d'ici 2027
et donc la transition électrique nous
devons l'amener en réindustrialisant en
investissant en soutenant l'achat le
véhicules électriques en incitant notre
filière nos constructeurs et l'ensemble
de l'écosystème à produire électrique en
France et en Europe on ne peut pas
renoncer à cet objectif on peut en
revanche confronter en construisant une
filière et c'est possible votre
département de la Seine-Maritime le
connaît avec les transformations en
cours des sites de Renault en
particulier à Cléon et à Dieppe ceux qui
paraissait improbable il y a quelques
années est en cours et donc se relever
ce défi de l'industrialisation
électrique en Europe nous pouvons le
faire cela nécessitera en effet réformer
nos outils de concurrence réformer nos
outils de protection commerciale allez
vers la réciprocité et faire en sorte
vous l'avez dit que les aides que nous
devons au consommateur et au
constructeurs ne soient pas ciblés vers
ceux qui de Chine essayent de gagner
notre marché aujourd'hui
merci quelques secondes monsieur Chauvet
non
merci monsieur le Président oui toute la
réponse était pas à la question
ceci étant vous avez évoqué le droit
européen je crois que ça mérite de s'y
pencher parce que je voudrais simplement
rappeler que au-delà des discours les
conséquences par ricochet sur l'emploi
dans cette filière automobile seront
terribles merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
votre collègues Vincent Segoin pour le
groupe les républicains vous avez la
parole
monsieur le ministre crise énergétique
difficulté d'approvisionnement et de
recrutement l'industrie est de plus en
plus affectée la situation des
trésorerie continue de se dégrader dans
tous les secteurs et très en deçà de la
moyenne de long terme conclusion du
rapport de la Banque de France sur la
conjoncture en octobre 2022 assez
difficultés se rajoutent le
remboursement du PGE et des charges
sociales qui n'ont pas été réclamées
depuis 2021 forcément ces charges
exceptionnelles sont trop lourdes pour
les entreprises et les rendre
vulnérables à ce sujet ici en commission
des finances nous vous avions déjà
alerté sur la durée de remboursement des
PGE que l'ont jugé incompatible avec la
marge des entreprises alors vous allez
me répondre que les entreprises peuvent
revoir la durée du remboursement du PGE
à condition de passer par la médiation
du crédit oui mais médiation est une
entité adossée à la Banque de France si
la réponse est négative l'entreprise
devra rentrer dans une procédure
collective si elle est positive
l'emprunt sera apparenté à
restructuration de la dette et donc
considérée comme des empreintes non
performants sur le bilan cela aura donc
un impact sur la cotation de
l'entreprise et quel qu'en soit la
taille bilan l'entreprise ne pourra plus
souscrire aux emprunts bancaires pour
innover aussi développer vous comprenez
alors pourquoi cette option est si peu
utilisé et pourquoi bon nombre de chefs
d'entreprise sera injectent leur
patrimoine personnel au risque de tout
perdre
l'entreprise France a une moyenne de 6
salariés toutes tailles confondues y
compris le CAC 40 vous avez entrepris
une démarche de réindustrialisation de
la France mais ne laissons pas tomber si
TPE et PME qui se découragent face à
cette situation pensez-vous ré-étaler le
PGE sans médiation particulière et
assure-toi temporairement le
remboursement des cotisations sociales
des années antérieures
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunication
monsieur Barrault merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur monsieur le sénateur merci pour
votre question qui est l'occasion de
rappeler à quel point les prêts garantis
par l'État les PGE ont permis au début
de la crise de la covid de sauver notre
tissu entrepreneurial avec 140 milliards
de près consentis dans votre département
de l'Orne ce sont plus de 260 millions
d'euros qui ont été prêtés à plus de
1700 entreprises désormais vous avez
raison de le rappeler se pose la
question du remboursement il n'y a pas
de risque systémique identifié à ce
stade sur sur ces sur ces prêts
garanties par l'État puisque le taux
prévisionnel de défaut sur ces prêts est
estimé aujourd'hui à 5%. mais évidemment
nous sommes conscients qu'un certain
nombre d'entreprises dans la conjoncture
actuelle rencontre des difficultés pour
les remboursements de ces prêts et c'est
la raison pour laquelle
ce dispositif qui a évolué tout au long
de la crise a fait l'objet d'une de
décision pour ouvrir des facultés
d'amortissement qui ont été prises en
juillet 2021 et en février 2022 et en
particulier pour les entreprises qui
avaient pris un prêt de moins de 50000
euros elles peuvent se tourner vers le
médiateur du crédit vous l'avez dit
placer auprès de la Banque de France
pour cela qui ont souscrit un prêt de
plus de 50000 euros elles peuvent se
tourner vers le conseiller départemental
de sortie de crise qui va les orienter
soit vers une solution de
restructuration de leur dette qu'elle
soit PGE ou qu'elle soit une dette des
Urssaf soit vers une procédure
préventive de conciliation vous avez
alerté sur la question de la notation
effectivement certaines entreprises sont
inquiète de voir leur note dégradée il
faut rappeler que pour les entreprises
qui font moins de 750 000 euros de
chiffre d'affaires celles-ci ne dispose
pas d'une notation FIBEN il n'y a donc
pas lieu qu'elle soit dégradée et seule
la banque en question sera au courant de
la restructuration pour celles qui font
plus de 750 000 euros il faut rappeler
la dégradation de la note n'est pas
systématique qu'elle fait l'objet d'une
analyse au cas par cas par la Banque de
France et que la discussion est ouverte
et je rappelle en conclusion que ces
facultés viennent en complément des
décisions qui ont été prises par la
première ministre pour venir en aide de
manière conjoncturelle à noterpe et PME
face à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
je vous remercie
monsieur
ce ministre déjà je suis surpris par
rapport à vos compétences que vous
répondiez à ma question première chose
la seconde vous tenez pas vous tenez
compte du taux de contentieux sans tenir
compte de la radiation des entreprises
qui est 37% supplémentaires à celui du
taux de 2019 les entreprises abandonnent
aujourd'hui on vous avait prévenu sur le
PGE que la durée de remboursement elle
serait trop courte vous faites vous le
600 votre réponse c'est circuler il y a
rien à voir et bien je suis désolé vous
étiez fier de défendre des entreprises
mais là vous les mettez dans le décor et
sans suivre navré
merci la parole à notre collègue Angèle
Préville pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et République merci monsieur
le président une condamnation pour
inaction avant-hier le Conseil d'État a
condamné l'État à une astreinte de 20
millions d'euros pour non-respect des
seuils de pollution de l'air en dioxyde
d'azote dans les grandes agglomérations
Paris Lyon Marseille et sur la période
du 1er juillet 2021 au 1er juillet 2022
22 l'État avait déjà été condamné il y a
un an pour les mêmes raisons à 10
millions d'euros cela sanctionne
l'insuffisance des mesures et moyens mis
en oeuvre pour ramener les émissions de
ce gaz sous le seuil de 40 microgrammes
par mètre cube principale émetteur les
moteurs thermiques soit le trafic
routier ce gaz le dioxyde d'azote se
dissout dans l'eau pour donner de
l'acide nitrique c'est d'ailleurs un
procédé de fabrication de la symétrique
produit corrosif par excellence très
concrètement si vous le respirez
mesdames et messieurs les ministres et
mes chers collègues dans votre nez dans
vos poumons qui sont humides le dioxyde
d'azote va ainsi dissoudre dans cette
humidité de l'acide nitrique dilué qui
va se former sur les parois de votre nez
et dans vos poumons c'est pourquoi vous
allez ressentir des picotements et des
irritations et si vous y êtes exposé
régulièrement des inflammations avec
pour conséquence des quantités de
pathologie chrysaces maladies pulmonaire
cancer du poumon les plus vulnérables
les enfants donc elle est plus pauvres
sont les plus touchées bilan annuels 40
000 décès prématurés dans la nature
c'est le même phénomène de formation
d'assignétrique au contact de l'eau qui
provoque plus acide acidification des
océans eurofisations des eaux douces et
qui constitue un facteur majeur de
baisse de la biodiversité or le trafic
routier par camion n'a pas baissé il
s'intensifie le frein de ferroviaire
n'est toujours pas revenu au niveau des
années 80 soit 30% du transport de
marchandises et les mobilités douces ne
sont toujours pas suffisamment
encouragés monsieur le ministre
pensez-vous que nous soyons sur la bonne
voie
vous répondre la parole est communiste
de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice nous avons
évidemment priacte du maintien par le
Conseil d'État de ces astreintes pour
les deux semestres depuis la
condamnation d'août 2021 je ne doute pas
compte tenu du degré de précision dans
lequel vous êtes entré que vous avez lu
cette avis du Conseil d'État qui pointe
le fait qu'il y a un maintien de
dépassement de seuil mais une
amélioration de la situation en 2017
nous avions 13 agglomérations qui
étaient en déplacement de seuil ce
chiffre est passé à 8 en 2020 à 5 en
2021 et il est de 3 Paris Lyon et
Aix-Marseille à la minute où nous
parlons mais le sujet c'est pas le
nombre d'agglo c'est bien d'abord le
nombre de décès plus de 40000 plus de 40
000 décès liées à la pollution de l'air
et notre engagement il est de faire en
sorte de diminuer ses décès
la ligne du gouvernement c'est la
protection des Français et cette
protection elle vaut d'abord sur les
sujets environnementaux façon
extrêmement concrète ce que le Conseil
d'État nous appelle c'est à amplifier à
renforcer ou à rendre plus efficiente
les zones affaiblission
mardi prochain je recevrai au ministère
avec les membres les présidents des
intercommunalités des métropoles les
maires de toutes les villes de plus de
150 000 habitants pour faire un point
sur là où nous en sommes une dizaine
d'agglomération y sont déjà passés
d'autre part certaines rencontres des
difficultés d'autres
anticipent des difficultés on a de vrais
sujets d'accessibilité sociale parce que
les aid effet ne doivent pas être des
moyens d'empêcher les plus fragiles
d'entrer dans les villes il y a donc la
question des compensations il y a la
question des moyens il y a la question
de l'information il y a des dispositifs
innovants avec Strasbourg qui teste un
passe avec d'autres qui majorent des
aides ou des primes à la conversion tous
ces sujets seront sur la table avec un
objectif protéger les Français
améliorer la qualité de l'air tout
particulièrement dans le domaine du
dioxyde d'azote et des particules fines
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Valérie Boyer pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la ministre j'associe à ma
question les amis de la justice et de la
liberté en particulier ceux du groupe
France Arménie le 13 septembre
l'Azerbaïdjan a lancé une nouvelle
offensive contre l'Arménie malgré
l'indifférence presque général c'est
bien une nouvelle guerre de conquête et
d'extermination qui se joue aux portes
de l'Europe avec son premier lot de
crime de guerre firmant exhibé sur la
toile par les militaires azerbaïdjanais
ce filmant dans leurs oeuvres de viol de
torture de démembrement cette logique
génocidaire cette arménophobie ce
racisme d'État pratiqué par
l'Azerbaïdjan avec le soutien de la
Turquie n'a pas vocation à s'arrêter à
ce pays il y a Malia a d'ailleurs
déclaré vouloir chassé ses chiens
d'Arméniens alors madame la ministre que
comptez-vous faire concrètement pour
éviter que cette part de l'histoire de
l'humanité que ce pays souverain la
République d'Arménie ne disparaisse
pour la parole est à Madame la Ministre
de l'Europe des Affaires étrangères
madame Colonna
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Boyer je vous
remercie de votre question qui me permet
qui me permet de revenir sur quelques
points évoquer récemment ici même la
France vous le savez est pleinement
solidaire de l'Arménie face aux
violations de sa souveraineté pour
stabiliser la situation pour que
l'Arménie recouvre son intégrité
territoriale et pour accompagner la
reprise des négociations cette
mobilisation porte ses fruits outre la
relance de la dynamique au Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies sous
présidence française les ministres des
Affaires étrangères de l'Union
européenne ont décidé lundi le lancement
rapide d'une mission européenne
d'observation qui se déplorera le long
de la frontière arménienne et cela a été
rendu possible par l'accord trouvé entre
les deux pays sous l'egers du président
de la République le 6 octobre au plus
étonnant dans la nuit du 7 octobre car
il a passé un certain temps comme le
souhaitait l'Arménie par ailleurs nous
avons aussi pu faire accepter une
mission d'évaluation de l'OSCE qui sera
sur place dès vendredi et permettra de
faire un constat de la situation et des
besoins notamment les besoins
humanitaires et visera la relance du
processus de négociation et de
délimitation de la frontière je vous
avais parlé de ces trois sujets et ils
ont avancé tout trois aucune de ces
avancées n'aurait été possible sans
l'engagement de la France jusqu'au plus
haut niveau de l'État madame la
sénatrice donc vous le voyez l'Arménie
peut compter sur la France c'est
l'oeuvre pour la paix et pour la
stabilité dans le Caucase dans l'intérêt
de tous je vous remercie
quand madame la ministre comment croire
une Europe qui d'un côté va envoyer
cette mission civile sur place mais qui
de l'autre renforce la coopération avec
l'Azerbaïdjan notamment en matière
énergétique avec une Ursula avant
derléans qui va en alias un partenaire
fiable sur lequel on peut compter
Bruxelles est prête à sacrifier la vie
des Arméniens sur le tel de ses intérêts
énergétiques qu'en est-il vraiment de la
France la vie des arts-médiens vaut-elle
vaut-elle moins que celle des Ukrainiens
cette tartufferie européenne ne va plus
loin puisque le gaz vendu par
l'Azerbaïdjan proviendrait d'une
exploitation en partie détenue par une
société russe l'Arménie est une part de
nous-mêmes une part de notre
civilisation de notre culture de nos
croyances nous avons même une journée
nationale pour commémorer le génocide de
1915 les Arméniens de demande qu'une
chose le droit de vivre le droit de
disposer d'eux-mêmes ce qui est valable
pour la Russie devrait l'être pour
l'autocratie azeri il y a d'ailleurs une
entente entre ces deux pays Poutine veut
prendre la géographie à l'if de annuler
l'histoire le premier conquiert le
second efface dit justement Sylvain
Tesson ce témoin demandant des sanctions
contre l'Azerbaïdjan et appliquons les
madame gelons les devoirs du clan à l'if
sans avoir la main qui tremble ou qui
triche opposant nous à la diplomatie de
la menace à la caviar connection
envisage envisageant un soutien
militaire pour l'Arménie des armes pour
l'Arménie ce que nous avons fait pour le
Mali pourquoi ne pas le faire pour
l'Arménie et dénonçons cet accord inique
sur le gaz car refusé ses sanctions
cautionner l'épuration ethniques des
Arméniens une nouvelle phase du génocide
peut-être la solution finale pour eux
malheureusement c'est clamer au monde
que les valeurs dont nous réclamons ne
sont que des supercheries alors agissons
concrètement
la parole est à notre collègue lors
d'Archos pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur
s'adresse à Monsieur
éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre la République a
toujours besoin de savon elle doit donc
commencer par favoriser les pépinières
scientifiques la réforme du lycée a été
bâclée avec comme seul objectif une
économie de moyens deux ans plus tard le
bilan que nous pouvons adresser est bien
inquiétant oui l'heure est grave
monsieur le ministre c'est toute une
filière qui est en train de couler nous
ne formons plus assez de scientifiques
alors même que la France a fait le choix
de réinvestir massivement dans la
recherche publique et l'innovation en
deux ans entre 2019 et 2021 le nombre
d'élèves scientifiques en terminale a
diminué de 24%. les élèves bénéficiant
d'un enseignement renforcé en
mathématiques sont de moins en moins
nombreux la part des jeunes filles dans
l'ensemble des parcours scientifiques
est aussi en chute libre 20 ans
d'efforts pour les amener à s'engager
dans des formations exigeantes autrefois
largement réservée aux garçons ont été
balayés d'un trait de plumes
les mathématiques la physique la chimie
le numérique les sciences informatiques
les sciences de l'ingénieur ont tout
disparu du tronc commun et sont
aujourd'hui relégués au rang
d'enseignement de spécialités ou
d'enseignement optionnel en Première et
en terminale les mesures annoncées à la
hâte à la fin de l'année scolaire
2021-2022 ne sont qu'un écran de fumée
vous ne pouvez pas décemment former un
ingénieur en lui enseignant 1h30 de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun en
première et trois heures d'options
mathématiques complémentaires pour tous
en terminale c'est toute la structure du
style terminal qu'il faut revoir sans
délai si nous voulons répondre à
l'exigence scientifique des formations
du supérieur et produire les compétences
dont dépend notre et nos coéconomie ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
elle dictée par l'urgence allez-vous
suspendre cette réforme et réunir toutes
les parties prenantes afin de réfléchir
à la mise en oeuvre de solutions
efficaces et durables pour renverser ce
déclin dès la rentrée 2023 à défaut je
crois que notre compatriote Hugo du
minil copain qui a reçu en juillet
dernier la médaille field pour ses
travaux en physique statistique et le
travail à Bures-sur-Yvette dans mon
département soit le dernier Français à
recevoir cette prestigieuse récompense
je vous remercie de votre votre réponse
[Musique]
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'heure d'Archos je vous
remercie de cette question qui m'offre
l'occasion de souligner deux points le
premier commence par un paradoxe l'école
française de mathématiques compte parmi
les meilleurs du monde c'est un sujet de
fierté pour notre pays 13 médailles-fils
des prix Nobel scientifiques y compris
cette année et d'un autre côté un niveau
moyen en mathématiques médiocre dans la
population générale et aussi dans la
population scolaire française on le voit
aux évaluations nationales mais aussi au
classement internationaux ou la place de
la France en mathématiques du côté des
populations scolaires n'est pas
reluisante face à cela nous avons
d'abord de façon rapide
réintroduit une heure et demie de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun pour
les élèves de première cela obéissait
une demande d'insistante des sociétés de
mathématiques et nous l'avons fait nous
allons poursuivre cet effort l'année
prochaine mais je le reconnais cela ne
suffit pas il faut avoir un regard
global sur l'enseignement des
mathématiques qui ne dépend pas du
volume de leur mathématiques car la
France se situe plutôt dans le haut du
panier en la matière en revanche quand
on regarde les résultats on voit que ça
n'a quoi cela ne correspond pas
évidemment à ce volume d'heures et donc
on a bien un sujet qui est le sujet de
la pédagogie de l'enseignement des
mathématiques comme le rapport toroscien
Villani là soulevé de façon très claire
le deuxième point que vous soulevez
c'est la place en baisse des filles dans
les dans les enseignements à une -28%
entre 2019 et 2021 c'est pourquoi je
vous annonce pour réfléchir et prendre
des mesures fortes en la matière je sais
que la première ministre est très
motivée par cette question
la tenue d'assise nationale sur la place
des femmes dans l'enseignement et dans
le monde scientifique cet automne avec
mes collègues ministres de
l'enseignement supérieur et de l'égalité
femme homme pour prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent je vous l'accorde c'est
désormais une priorité pour nous nous
devons en tenir compte dans les
retouches que nous allons faire de la
réforme du lycée
merci
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
d'actualité les prochaines auront lieu
mercredi 26 octobre je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen d'approvision de loi
constitutionnelle visant à protéger à
garantir le droit fondamental à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et la contraception la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement du Sénat que
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur l'antenne depuis 15h
parmi les temps forts aujourd'hui on
retient cet échange tendu entre le chef
de fil des sénateurs LR Bruno Retailleau
et la chef du gouvernement et les avait
de borne Bruno Retailleau a évoqué le
drame du meurtre de l'adolescente de 12
ans Lola retrouvée morte vendredi à
Paris lorsqu'il a pris la parole on est
entendu dans les mystiques